sur silence et Notre-Dame-des-Landes je
reviendrai pas sur les questions
précédentes et je pense que c'est
effectivement une partie d'un
complaisance de lutte à gauche qui nous
touche tous et je pense avoir en partie
répondu à Monsieur à Monsieur Bastien
moi j'ai pas mises à l'intérieur à
l'époque mais c'est sûr que lorsque vous
faites des opérations qui relevé d'une
opération extrêmement importante de
d'évacuation de la ZAD avec ce que
disait les enseignements à l'époque là
aussi je pense que c'est intéressant de
les de les consulter des morts de chaque
côté manifestants et policiers
gendarmerie la décision était prise de
ne pas le faire est-ce que c'était bien
de pas le faire c'est votre opinion
politique je la respecte encore faut-il
que il ne fallait pas laisser installer
en train de des Landes donc c'est très
difficile d'évacuer des ALD on peut pas
dire c'est extrêmement dangereux et donc
le mieux c'est d'éviter qu'elle
s'installe donc pour l'avenir moi je ne
peux être que d'accord avec vous son
autorité de l'État monsieur Center pour
l'avenir empêchant vous parlez de la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme je connais
pas les subventions données par l'État
mais effectivement je pense que ça
mérite ça mérite d'être regardé dans le
cadre des actions qu'ils ont pu mener
mais je rappelle que beaucoup de
collectivités locales aussi les finances
voilà là mais je le dis représentant des
collectivités locales également que vous
êtes voilà donc ce n'est pas qu'une
question il n'y a pas que